[Music]
Kate Hudson is expecting baby number
three
the actress posted this video on Friday
revealing the happy news and sharing her
baby's gender yes with that adorable
gender reveal balloon pop Kate told fans
she's having a baby girl this will be
her first daughter the actress has been
dating singer and guitarist Danny
Fujikawa for over a year she captioned
the baby girl announcement video quote
we have been trying to keep this
pregnancy under the radar for as long as
possible but I'm popping now my kids
Danny myself and the entire family are
crazy excited Hudson has two sons from
previous relationships with musicians
Chris Robinson and Matt Bellamy the 38
year old also shared that she's been
sick with this pregnancy quote if you've
wondered why I've been so absent on my
social channels it's because I have
never been more sick it was the most
sick first trimester of all my children
Kate said even scrolling through
Instagram stories made her ill and
exhausted but we couldn't be happier for
Kate and her family it's just it's
growing and growing
[Music]